when you were writing 25 years old for
saturday night live do you remember the
first thing you got on air
yes what was it i was writing a lot of
weird [ __ ] at the time
and failing miserably there was a sketch
like a candid camera sketch which was
like
practical jokes on animals so it was
like
get a load take a look at this goat
react to the moving mailbox
it's just a live goat and the goat has
no reaction
one of the best sketches i think that
you ever wrote was the uh
clucky the chicken or something that's
mine that's maybe my favorite snl sketch
that i ever
it is fantastic one of the customers is
like hey clucky
how is it that the your chicken is so
darn
good it's because i'm flame broiled
and then he's like they show you the
flames and then they
and then he takes you through the whole
process first they chop my head off
bam you see his head tumble in the sky
and it's just so [ __ ] sadistic it's
awful it'll make you stop eating chicken
it's such a great sketch so so how do
you get that gig like well how does one
at 25 years old prove to them that
you're good enough i'm so lucky
i was so lucky i was performing in
chicago
with some friends of mine that i had
made so we formed a very successful
comedy group and then this guy
in my group dave reynolds who ended up
writing fi
co-writing finding nemo a really funny
guy
he got cast in a movie that al franken
and tom davis
were making in chicago and so al franken
and tom davis ended up coming
to our show and
they really liked our show and they took
us out for
beer afterward and i thought that's
great that's like
kind of a validation let's keep going
we're doing good
but then like two weeks later um
i found out that lauren michaels was
coming back to saturday night live
and he's hiring al franken and tom davis
as his producers and i was like holy
[ __ ]
i know somebody at saturday night live i
can't believe this
franken and davis gave you your break
and they got they introduced 100
how do you audition as a writer do you
just submit um different sketches you've
written
um yes i i submitted a writer's packet
some of the stuff from the show but then
i wrote other
stuff and and they liked it so i i can't
believe to this day that that i got
hired